what is different about the bear Market
that we're heading into now maybe even a
recession compared to past ones
yeah it's it's a big [ __ ] a big change I
think anyone in uh you know who's been
investing in the last 40 years has kind
of seen one kind of Federal Reserve
right and that response is almost
immediate uh you know when s p is down
10 15 you start typically start hearing
the chatter about they got they should
do something either send a message that
they're going to expand the balance
sheet or cut interest rates some
combination thereof so the last eight
bear markets in the U.S we've seen that
exact response we saw it in 2020 of
course with the immediate move down to
zero in terms of interest rates and then
the biggest expansion of the balance
sheet that we've ever seen But even
before that in 2018 we saw them
immediately stop hiking rates and then
start cutting rates and launch another
round of QE so pretty much every bear
Market even the 1987 crash that's really
where it started under Alan Greenspan
you've seen the FED ease into that today
very much different in situation the FED
has already hiked rates a few times and
they're expected to continue to hike
rates to above three percent by the end
of the year so kind of ignoring that uh
decline in the market and and the reason
is because we haven't seen inflation be
the threat it is today since the early
1980s so the last time we had a bear
Market where the FED took a hawk this
position uh in the midst of that it was
under Paul volcker in the early 1980s
and were faced with kind of a similar uh
market today except that the FED today
is so far uh behind that curve
So when you say that they're behind the
curve one of the things uh it feels like
is they were still you know doing asset
purchases earlier this year uh even
though they were talking tough at the
exact time like how do you analyze uh
what they're saying versus what they're
doing and is there any kind of
Frameworks that you've
um you know kind of distilled over time
that that really helps you uh separate
words from actions
yeah it was just an incredible
disconnect right we saw last year even
even if you thought that you know
heading into 2021 let's say you had the
uh position that inflation wasn't going
to be a problem by the middle of the
year it was clear uh pretty clear to
everyone that inflation was rising and
and particularly in the housing market
we saw month after month of record highs
and and demand really fueling that so
there was in my opinion and I think any
reasonable person's opinion there was no
rational reason to continue to buy
mortgage bonds uh last year and into
this year with the housing market doing
what it did and zero percent rates uh
just made zero sense last year given the
risk reward of the situation so their
number one job uh you know as a Fed
under their mandate is to control uh you
know to have price stability and you
know they had the low unemployment rate
so that really wasn't a factor and they
just kind of ignored it and uh and we
find ourselves in the position today
where they're behind the curve and so
they have to be uh you know rapidly
catching up so you know really the pain
that could have been avoided was just
that additional excess and upside in
terms of the mean stocks and everything
else in terms of people jumping into
risk forced into risky assets uh and now
we're seeing the other side of that
unfortunately why do you think that they
continued was it uh they just didn't
want to rock the boat was it something
like politically motivated was it just
ignorance what was it yeah I think it's
a combination
thereof uh the politics the FED
unfortunately has gotten more and more
political I think we've seen that in
recent years and especially with the
huge increase in national debt right we
added six trillion dollars that didn't
happen in a vacuum that couldn't have
happened without the FED monetizing that
and and buying a good chunk of that uh
debt and adding it to their balance
sheet so to me that was that was really
the politicization of the fed and uh the
FED has kind of had this idea that uh
the base case scenario should be easing
and and that started under Greenspan but
it really accelerated under Bernanke and
the idea was that uh you easing should
should always be preferable because
we're not really worried about inflation
and if you're not worrying about
inflation why not ease why not uh you
know just make that your base case
scenario of course uh anyone in Emerging
Markets countries can tell you why right
they've experienced that and anybody
living in the 1970s could tell you why
as well but it was just too far removed
from us uh for that to be a real concern
and so uh you know that pass it on to
the next fed and same thing with what
the government does pass it on to the
next uh you know so we'll continue uh
doing what we're doing until we're
really forced to uh to move and now
they're in the position where really
they they've lost most of the
credibility I believe that they had but
if they want to retain any credibility
here they have to start moving higher
and it's only only because of that
they're really being forced to that
they're doing so and and so at a certain
point here we'll likely see them flip
and go back in the opposite direction
but the Optics today are two are too
much for them to just simply ignore
right we have the lowest consumer
confidence in history uh we have gas
prices above five dollars a gallon for
the first time in history you have any
number of factors but inflation is the
main reason people are feeling angst and
for good reason their wages are not
keeping up uh with uh with the inflation
now for 14 consecutive months uh and and
that's a lot and uh and so the FED
really has to try to at least do
something about it so when you start to
look at uh the data that they are using
obviously CPI is uh the thing that
everyone's been paying attention to for
the last year or so I appreciate uh the
fact that we probably see eye to eye on
uh uh it's [ __ ] like there's just no
way that the CPI prints appear to be
accurate
and can you walk us through like why you
don't think the CPI measurement is is uh
maybe reflecting what they think it's
reflecting
yeah the big factor today you know I'm
not one of these people who thinks that
historically and you know inflation it
was 10 and it was really two percent you
know certainly it's it's probably a bit
higher than the reported figures if
you're going back let's say 20 30 years
but I think the big disconnect has been
in the past uh year or so and looking at
the housing numbers and housing you know
as you know is the biggest component of
CPI it's what people spend most of their
budget on uh over 33 of that indexes
just in housing and they just have an
Antiquated measure in my view and they
they have some justifications for it of
measuring uh the cost of housing cost of
shelter we're really instead of looking
at market prices whether it's rents
which are up 15 over the last year or
housing prices nationally which are up
over 20 which is the highest increase
we've seen year over year on record uh
they're going around and polling people
and asking them uh what they would rent
their homes out for something called
owner's equivalent rent and when they do
that apparently the answers to those
polls are much lower than the actual
statistics so because of that you know
that 8.6 figure if we're using you know
the actual housing inflation that we've
seen over the past year uh you know
would would obviously be uh well above
10 so it's just a function you know
that's the Big Driver in in terms of the
index and maybe you know over the long
run that Smooths itself out but you know
over the past year that's been just you
know really Under reporting the actual
rate of inflation uh you know in the
economy how do you think about uh the
demand for Real Estate once uh rates
start to increase we have seen the
mortgage uh rate explode upwards uh is
this just a simple Supply demand hey
demand cools the rates go up we should
expect real estate prices to fall and
like don't make this too complicated
keep it simple
yeah I mean there's it's not it's not as
simple as that as the stock market where
it replay prices very quickly but it has
to impact demand and we're seeing that
already so the mortgage rate bottomed at
2.65 in early 2021 and uh it's it's
doubled since then and so if you're
looking at the the uh payment right the
average payment if you put 20 down uh
it's pretty much doubled over that
period of time and you have phone prices
up you know 20 30 percent uh since then
so uh if that doesn't impact demand then
then nothing will and it is already if
we looked at uh new home sales last
month they really collapsed and I think
we'll see that uh continue uh and you
know the housing market uh you know this
is really the second bubble we've seen
in the housing market and uh it could
have it to some extent been avoided I I
don't think it should be a national
policy that we've kind of made it in
terms of of the the FED saying that we
want want to create these housing
bubbles uh that and the theory was that
under the wealth effect of people's
homes went up in price uh then they
would spend more money and and that is
true to a certain extent in the short
run uh but you don't want to create a
situation where housing is unaffordable
uh based on incomes we saw that in the
mid 2000s and now we're seeing again
today it's at the lowest affordability
you got to go back to 07 uh you know to
see that and that's not good for an
economy long run you want housing to be
an affordable because it's not a
productive good so you know driving
prices up uh you know ahead of
fundamentals for the housing markets bad
for everyone right it increases your
taxes increases Insurance uh you know
we've seen all these things go up so uh
I'm not sure what the thinking is beyond
again that theoretical concept which is
we just want asset prices to go up so
people spend more uh I I think hopefully
people will learn after uh the housing
market comes in here and we don't have
to see a collapse like we did the last
time but you have to see a normalization
you just can't have long-term uh housing
prices stretched in relations to income
it's it you know it has to give one way
or another either you loosen lending
standards which we don't want to see
right we don't want to see it go back to
having subprime and and people only
putting a few percent down or credits
people lying about their incomes that's
one way to avoid the collapsor too is we
just have to take the medicine and say
that's seven times uh you know home
prices are seven times now uh the above
incomes and that's the highest we've
ever seen and perhaps that's too much
and perhaps we shouldn't pursue that as
a goal you know as a policy right so
just letting the market instead of uh
the FED determine uh you know where
housing prices should be I think I think
that makes sense why do we in trust
really is a big question not just for
housing but for the stock market for the
economy in general why do we trust that
10 people sitting in a room can
determine the most important interest
rate in the economy me I'm not sure why
we do that right we wouldn't do that
with food uh that you know where we
somehow we seem to to go to the grocery
store and have food each week and
there's not some Central planner uh
figuring out you know what quantities to
put in different amounts and how much to
produce right the Market's driving that
uh so why should it be different with
interest rates we're really entrusting
these people uh you know giving them a
lot of responsibility giving them
um perhaps the the respect that they
don't deserve because based on history
they've gotten it wrong how many times
right uh you know and I'm gonna say I
would do any better right but you know
leaving them to determine what the
interest rates should be or or when they
should buy bonds or not buy bonds and
you know it just seems misguided because
it's going to lead to a misallocation of
capital right you're driving people into
asset classes based on that interest
rate that manipulated interest rate
rather than the underlying fundamentals
right of that sector hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
Channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time